se pressent comme chaque samedi dans
cette petite librairie de bord de loire
s'amuser en compte la crise sanitaire a
révélé le profond attachement des
français à ce commerce de proximité qui
a rejoint en mars 2021 la liste des
commerces dits essentiels
je trouve que c'est formidable c'était
absolument nécessaire
j'ai été très malheureuse et premiers
mois de l'année dernière sans librairie
moi c'est ma passion c'est je trouve que
ça remplace presque tous deux de
s'évader dans les livres pour moi c'est
essentiel
on adore venir ici et quand on était
confiné sans pouvoir venir on avait vite
fait le tour de la bibliothèque de la
maison aussi est aussi importante soit
elle et du coup venir ici pour avoir des
conseils des coups de coeur et bien
c'est très très important pour nous ça
fait partie de notre vie
ouverte il y a tout juste quatre ans
cette librairie installés en milieu
rural doit sa pérennité à la loi lang
voter en 1981 elle instaurera un prix
unique pour le livre sans la loi lang il
y aurait plus de librairies
indépendantes en france serait plus de
petites librairies il y aurait pas mal à
ça aurait complètement fait disparaître
le maillage des librairies en fait parce
que ça ça aurait ouvert la porte à de la
concurrence en fait et et une petite
librairie peut pas concurrencer amazon
de ce qu'on parle d' amazon on parle de
la fnac la loi lang continue d'inspirer
d'autres pays en europe la belgique et
la grèce s'apprête à adopter le principe
du prix unique pour le livre
contrairement à l'angleterre ou les
librairies indépendantes ont quasiment
disparu du paysage culturel